Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
Daniel Lubetzky, the founder
of the groundbreaking
snack company KIND,
returns to the Tank.
Are you or your parents
from Ghana?
Yes.
Were you born
on Wednesday?
Yeah. How does he
know this stuff?
Necessity is the fairy godmother
of invention.
Who's "eggcited"?
Here it is!
Greiner: Oh. [ Laughs ]
Ohh!
Oh, my goodness.
Are you kidding?
You think this is worth
$10 million?
Guys, I've doubled the amount
of cash you're getting.
Lori, are you in on this deal
with me?
You're kicking Daniel
to the curb?
Yes, I'm throwing him
under the bus.
I'm using my social media
to back this.
I'm offended.
It's stupid.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a high‐protein option
for snackers.
[ Laughs ]
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Nick Hamburger.
I'm Zack Schreier.
We're here
from Chicago, Illinois,
seeking $200,000
in exchange for 5% "egguity"
in our venture Quevos.
Sharks, sometimes it's
the snacks we love dearly
that hurt us the most.
When people realize that their
favorite snacks aren't healthy,
they often experience
the five stages of grief.
First, we see denial, where
we just can't handle the truth.
Potato chips
are veggies, right?
[ Laughs ]
Then comes anger.
Empty calories!
White flour!
After that,
there's bargaining,
where we hold on
to false hope.
Blue corn
tortilla chips?
I mean, come on, these ‐‐ these
have got to be healthier
than yellow corn
tortilla chips, right?
Fourth,
we see depression.
What's the point of snacking
when you always get hurt?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Sharks,
we see acceptance.
We make peace
with the fact
that our favorite snacks
will never be healthy for us.
Now, Sharks,
that's where we come in.
We've created
the healthy snack
to save people from
this vicious snacking cycle.
Quevos!           Quevos!
Quevos are the world's
first‐ever chips
made from egg whites.
This is the snack that's both
delicious and healthy.
Wow.
Quevos are packed
with eight grams of protein
and four grams of fiber
in every serving.
And our keto flavors only have
four net carbs per bag.
The days of starchy, fried,
and processed snacks
made from potatoes and tortillas
are done.
Now, Sharks,
who's "eggcited"
to crack out of their shell
with Quevos?
Who wants to try
some samples?
Love to.
Tell us what we have.
Cuban: Absolutely.
So here we have
our two classic flavors,
cheddar
and sweet barbecue,
and then two
of our keto flavors,
sour cream and onion
and dill pickle.
Taste good.
We have over 500
five‐star reviews on Amazon
out of 800 reviews.
I love them.
Oh, so glad to hear that.
That's awesome.
Tasty and light.
Yeah, I really do.
They have the same amount
of calories as normal chips.
Exactly.
But much more volume.
It's better
than a typical snack.
With all that fiber
and protein,
you walk away from each bag
feeling much more satisfied.
How long ago
did you launch this?
Yeah, so we launched this
in 2018.
We did a Kickstarter.
We raised $72,000...
Wow.
...and started launching
retail later that year.
And what did you sell
last year?
$260,000 in sales
last year.
Wow. Wow.
This year we've done $660,000
through the first seven months,
on pace
for $1.3 million.
And what percentage is online?
Just use this year.
So 80% of our sales
are online,
20% in retail,
where we're in 400 stores.
Tell me what it costs you
to make one bag like this
and what you sell them for.
Sure, so it costs us 83 cents
to make a bag.
We sell to distributors
for $1.50,
online for $2.50 to $3.
And then the price that we see
at the end of the day
after referral fees
are $2.49.
That's also the MSRP.
The process is all automated
now with a co‐packer?
We manufacture ourselves,
actually.
We have a unique process,
and so we kind of had to
scale it ourselves.
We talk to co‐packers,
and we will continue
to speak with them as we grow.
But so far, the quotes
they've given us
have been
up to two times our cost.
How do you make it?
So we can tell you
it's not fried.
That's the most
important part,
but it is a proprietary
and novel process.
So we can't disclose
the details.
It's baked, right?
It's not.
I'm just wondering
how two chicken dudes
figured this out.
Greiner: It's not?
I guess it all started
10 years ago.
So, I was diagnosed
with type 1 diabetes,
and I went from being a kid
who loved to snack all the time,
didn't think about it,
to being somebody
that had to watch every single
carb I put into my body.
And I realized one day
those crispy pieces of egg white
that coated the pan
when I made an omelet,
they crunched
kind of like chips.
I thought, "Hey, maybe I can
make a chip out of this."
And that took myself ‐‐
That's a great call
right there,
'cause that crunchy stuff
is good.
Fast‐forward about eight years,
as we're going to college.
I revisited the idea,
called Nick up,
and we got to work on it.
I am the CEO.
We have seven full time
on production.
What does Zack do
all day long?
When we really got going
our sophomore year of college,
I took one year off
of Williams College
to basically get this product
from concept
to finished,
shelf‐ready products.
Now, Nick and I
talk about strategy.
I sit on the board.
But you have
a different job.
I'm back at
Williams College now.
Are you guys both
out of college?
Or one's in, one's out?
Yeah, so after
my sophomore year,
I dropped out
of University of Chicago.
And so now I've had
two years full time on
this business, and ‐‐
You haven't even
finished college yet?
Yeah.
How old are you guys?
Herjavec: Wow.
22.
‐22?
‐You're kidding?
Yeah.
Nick, how much money
have you raised?
$1.6 million to date.
Wow.
Who did you raise that from
and for how much?
Kraft Heinz invested
a little bit.
Come on.
Yeah.
How did you get
introduced to them?
We were in their
incubator program.
We were actually
the only pre‐revenue brand
ever accepted
to their incubator.
You two
are two impressive...
Lubetzky: Very much
...guys.
Zack and Nick, 83 cents
cost of production per bag
is pretty high.
What's your ideal price point
that you're targeting?
At the end of the day,
$1.99 a bag
we think would be
the lowest we need to go.
Well, you're definitely smart
to start higher,
because once you start low,
you can never go up.
But if you start high,
you can always go down.
Exactly.
So who came up
with the name?
We were thinking of "eggs"
in other languages.
We thought of "huevos,"
and then someone's like,
"Well, they're quick huevos.
They're eggs on the go."
And so we combined
"quick" and "huevos."
So it's Spanglish.
Yeah, it's cute.
What about marketing?
How much have you guys been
spending on marketing and where?
So online we usually spend about
$20,000 a month on marketing.
Last month,
we did $90,000 online sales.
So we're seeing
a good return.
Zack, I think you guys
probably two of the youngest,
most impressive people
we've ever had out here.
But I don't like the taste.
I know you're
gonna do well.
It's just not for me.
I'm out.
Thank you so much, Robert.
No worries.
O'Leary: I love this deal.
I mean, the story ‐‐
the innovation
from the fried eggs,
I love that.
You're not loving the pricing.
I mean ‐‐
No, I don't.
I tell you what.
I'd structure
a little differently.
In this case, I would
do this deal for $200,000
and I'd put a royalty
of 10 cents a bag
until I get back $400,000.
Wait, wait,
wait for it.
But I would only take
2.5% equity.
So I get to participate.
You get into the "Shark Tank"
Dome of Desire, as I call it.
I would help you
on digital like crazy.
I would prefer to sell this
direct to customer
than through Amazon.
Work together with my companies
to go direct.
We are killing it direct.
Lubetzky: What's your vision?
What do you ‐‐
What would be success
for you?
Yeah, our hope
is to sell the company
on a three‐
to five‐year timeline.
Why?
We've seen in this space,
it can be perilous to hang on to
your brand the bigger it grows,
because the big guys
will at some point
either want to buy you
or knock you off.
I actually don't blame you
for having a very
well‐thought‐through answer.
But the problem
that Mr. Wonderful mentioned
is a serious one.
5% is very hard to justify.
The valuation's
pretty crazy.
We came into the Tank
hoping not to give away
too much equity
at this stage.
But, you know,
it's worth it
to give more than 5%
to have you on board.
We'd be willing
to come up to 10%.
Even for more cash,
you wouldn't go to 15%, 20%?
We could consider
an offer,
but, you know, our goal was
to minimize the dilution.
At the same time, we really want
you involved and want you ‐‐
You know,
if a Shark gets involved,
we want them to be motivated
and really bought in, so...
Herjavec:
You guys are so solid.
Greiner: I know.
Hamburger: Thank you.
Like, I'm just sitting here.
It's a pleasure
watching you guys.
Lubetzky: Zack and Nick,
I'm going to make you an offer.
I'll do $200,000 for 10%.
Thank you so much
for the offer.
Would you mind if Nick and I
talked about it for a minute?
I don't mind.
Don't forget the other offer.
Does anyone else ‐‐
Would anyone else like to ‐‐
Greiner: And listen,
I will tell you something.
I'm already your customer.
Awesome.
I love it.
I think Daniel's
a perfect partner for you.
I don't.
I think Mr. Wonderful is.
[ Laughs ] I think Daniel's
a perfect partner for you.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you so much, Lori.
Thank you, Lori.
But we haven't heard
from Mr. Cuban.
Cuban: So the question I have
is, what comes next?
Exit is great, right?
My whole goal when I started was
to retire by the time I was 35,
because the one thing
you can never buy is time.
Right?
So I don't mind that at all.
But I have a feeling that
you guys have more on your mind
in terms of breadth
of product line
in order to make this a brand,
like Daniel's alluding to.
So that's what I'd like
to hear.
I think we view egg whites
as really the cornerstone
of the brand.
They let us make things
that are crunchy,
delicious,
high in protein.
What else can you make
with egg whites?
Quite a lot, so you can
make puffs, protein cookies.
Guys, you wanted to go talk.
I just want to tell you,
I can't do less than 10%.
That's my floor number, so...
And I'll make it easier
for you guys.
I think you don't have
that one slam‐dunk thing,
so you always have to
get people to sample.
That's gonna be
a challenge.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Well, thank you, Mark.
Okay, thank you, Mark.
You still have
two fantastic offers.
I really like Mr. Wonderful's.
He's a great guy.
And the Kraft Heinz guys
love me.
Just want you to know that.
Good to know.
You have two offers.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
But Zack and Nick have
two offers on the table
for their egg‐white chips,
Quevos.
You have two offers.
What are you gonna do?
So we'd love to counter
to Daniel first
just because of all
of your experience with KIND.
And so we're gonna counter
with 300K
and a line of credit
for that 10% stake.
Herjavec:
How much of a line of credit?
Maybe a $200,000 line of credit
or purchase‐order funding.
Can you go up
on the percentage equity?
We'd prefer to come down on the
cash to $250,000 in that case.
Here's what I'll do.
I'll give you
$200,000 investment
and a $200,000 line of credit
for a 10% stake.
♪♪
What was the other counter?
Lubetzky: How about it?
How about you just say yes?
No, I want to hear
the other offer.
Herjavec: Bird in the hand.
Daniel, would it be okay
if we shared the other
counter with Kevin?
Yeah, of course it is.
I don't think so.
Greiner: No.
I give you that permission.
That's true. That's true.
$250,000.
Guys, I've doubled the amount
of cash you're getting.
If you're not
sufficiently excited,
I think I'm going to come out.
How about just 300K for 10%,
none of the credit?
Guys, the numbers,
I'm really doing ‐‐
Can you give me 12%?
How about 10% plus 2%
advisory shares, $300,000?
That's too high.
$200,000,
200K line of credit, 10%.
You'd rather do that
than $300,000 and 12%?
Yeah.
We got a deal?
Daniel, how about what you said
prior to our counter?
$200,000, $200,000
line of credit, 10%?
You got a deal.
Alright!
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Good job.
You guys are gonna kill it.
Greiner: You did a great deal.
Cuban: Well done.
Thank you so much, Daniel.
Thank you, guys.
Looking forward
to working with you.
Thank you. Great work.
Cuban: Well done, guys.
Good job, guys.
Alright.
Whoo!
That's crazy.
We made a deal.
[ Both laugh ]
With Daniel, too.
That's unbelievable.
Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
Wow.
We just pitched
on "Shark Tank."
We're only 22 years old.
We've been coming up
with different businesses
our whole lives and wanting
to run them together.
And so the fact that we got to
go on "Shark Tank" together
and get a deal from Daniel,
who's a giant
in the food industry,
it's a boy's dream.
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 11,
Cassidy Crowley
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for her hybrid teether
and baby spoon, The Baby Toon.
This is a great product.
Narrator:
Let's see what she's up to now.
Crowley: Right after we aired
on "Shark Tank,"
our sales grew overnight.
Just within the first month,
we had over $100,000 in sales.
We like that.
Greiner: A few months after
I made the deal with Cassidy,
I went to Hawaii,
and we decided that Munchkin
was gonna be our goal.
Munchkin is one of
the world leaders
in baby and children products.
They were her dream,
and they've been a dream
to work with, as well.
To work with you
and my favorite Shark, Lori,
was a dream come true.
And we are now proud
to tell you
it will be
in over 5,000 stores.
So exciting!
Crowley: Munchkin is now
handling product development,
distribution, manufacturing,
and so much more.
I can still design new products,
and I'm on the back
of every Baby Toon sold.
Oh, my gosh, look!
The Baby Toon is now
in Target, Walmart,
and also in online stores like
Amazon and the Munchkin website.
For every Baby Toon sold,
we donate to the International
Fund of Animal Welfare.
Some of our sales
will go to protect animals
and their habitats.
Greiner: I think Cassidy's
going to set the world on fire.
I think she'll do great things
for humanity
and not only for herself,
but for others.
Crowley: Now I have more time
to do stuff that I enjoy doing,
like going surfing
and dancing hula.
And it also allows me to come up
with new ideas in the future.
This experience has taught me
that anyone in the world
has the opportunity
to create their own business.
Just getting to experience
all this,
it's just a dream come true.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way
to get the freshest cup
of coffee on the go.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Kweku Larbi.
I'm about to introduce you
to the most revolutionary,
most innovative coffee maker
that will change
the game entirely.
Are you guys ready for this?
Herjavec: Yes.
Here it is!
Greiner: Oh. [ Laughs ]
Ohh!
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh!
You think that piece of junk is
gonna change the game of coffee?
You're crazy!
You're probably wondering,
who's this guy
who's been sitting in
a coffee cup for the last hour?
My name's Ross Smith.
I'm a social media influencer.
I have over 45 million followers
across all platforms.
And my mission is
to make the world smile.
Our friend Kweku created
a solution that was so good
that I had to
partner up with them.
And together, we both created
the one and only Brumachen.
The Brumachen is a single‐serve
portable brewer
that makes a hot cup of coffee
at a push of a button.
So no more waiting
in long lines
or stalling
in drive‐throughs.
I've taken the Brumachen
all around the world ‐‐
in cabs, on boats,
camping, you name it.
It is extremely portable.
It is.
And now Kweku will show you
how it works.
Sharks, pay attention
to the screen.
First, you plug it in.
You pour your water in.
Doesn't matter temperature.
You insert any
single‐serve coffee pod.
Oh, wow.
And at a push of a button and
a short five‐minute wait, guys,
you have a fresh cup of coffee
ready to go...
Cool.
...anywhere, anytime.
[ Chuckles ]
Now we'd like to ask you
for $1 million
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
And one cup of coffee.
You know what?
It's giving season.
Two cups of coffee.
Two cups of coffee!
There we go.
Who's sold?
Well, Sharks, we're gonna
make a brew right now.
Ross, can you please get me
a coffee pod from that tent?
Huh.
Oh, man.
What the heck, Kweku?!
Yeah, Ross, that's
1,000 coffee pods.
That's the amount the average
American will use this year
when they use single‐serve
plastic pods.
Bro, this is so wasteful.
It's absolutely wasteful.
It's why at Brumachen, we didn't
stop at one innovation.
We went beyond.
We created this.
It's a biodegradable
single‐serve coffee pod
made out of materials
like sugar cane and tree fibers.
Guys, those pods take
450 years to biodegrade.
This takes 180 days.
We don't got time for that.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
No, man, that's messed up.
Truly.
Sharks,
you have the opportunity
to put your money into something
that isn't just a product.
It goes beyond that.
It preserves the planet
for the next generation.
Well, Sharks, you ready to make
Brumachen the next big thing?
Kweku, are you or your parents
from Ghana?
Yes.
Were you born
on Wednesday?
Yeah. How does he
know this stuff?
Wow.
Magician right there.
That's crazy.
People from the Asante tribe,
they name their children
based on the day of the week
that they're born.
Exactly.
So, guys, your coffee pod,
you twist the top off,
twist it in half.
And twist it in half.
Then you take your coffee pod,
puncture it right in there.
Push it in.
Then take the nipple off.
And you pour
the water in.
And twist really tight.
Really tight.
Yeah, you should feel it lock.
And then we press
the blue button.
Yes, and then you press
the power button.
Tell me, how did you
come up with this?
Well, I work construction.
I'm a civil engineer.
So I was in a field
with the guys in the winter.
And I live in Indiana.
Construction guys, they're out
there in the freezing cold.
And they had to go 10‐minute
drive to get a cup of coffee
and come back
to the site.
And that's like 20 minutes.
If you multiply that
by 10 workers,
you're spending a pretty buck
on coffee, you know.
So my goal was,
how do you bridge in between
having a coffee machine at home
and in an office?
But when you're on the go
in between those spaces,
your only option
is to buy.
And I was like, we could make
something that could actually
keep that self‐brewing feature
in coffee.
So people can now do that
with our machine.
How much is it?
It's $120 retail.
Greiner: And why does it
cost you to make?
$38.
Do you have a patent?
Yeah, I have a utility patent
pending
for both the pods
and the machine.
Lubetzky:
Can you tell us a little bit
about how did you go
from Ghana to Indiana?
Well, I grew up in Ghana.
At 17, I graduated
from high school,
and I decided I would chase
a career of civil engineering
in the United States.
So I kind of kissed
my family goodbye
and I arrived in United States
with $2,000 in my pockets.
I arrived on campus
in Cleveland State,
and I ended up
working a job
scrubbing toilets in the morning
at 5:30 a. m.
to make money
to keep myself going.
Greiner: Wow. So what is
your role in this?
You're a social media
influencer?
What do you do?
So, yeah, a little bit
of background about me.
I over the last eight years have
gotten billions of impressions
and views and over
45 million followers.
You look over here, my
94‐year‐old grandmother,
who's my co‐star,
and we've been doing it together
the whole entire time.
Herjavec: Oh, wow.
Everything's with
your grandma?
Not everything,
but she's my main star.
So I have the ability to push
products and push people.
And that's kind of why I'm here.
But what's your role
in the company?
I'm marketing.
This is my brand.
I'm using my social media
to back this.
I'm pushing it
with all my might.
For the last week,
I got 100 million impressions
just on my platforms.
Well, then
let's get to sales.
We started on Kickstarter.
We sold 600 units
in January.
Did you deliver
the Kickstarter units yet?
Yes, we have.
You can tell it's designed
by an engineer
because it's all built
around functionality
as opposed to looks, right?
Yes.
It looks a little bit
like a spaceship, right?
I always say it looks
like a camera lens.
And that's what's missing.
You did how much in revenue
on your Kickstarter?
$42,000.
Just tell me
your total sales.
Okay, $42,000 to date.
That's it?
Yes, that's all we did.
Mr. Wonderful.
Please.
Oh, my goodness.
Are you kidding?
You think this is worth
$10 million?
Absolutely.
Now I'm gonna rip you to pieces.
Are you out of your mind?
Why would you think
this is worth $10 million?
Well, because
just my push alone,
I can get 100 million
impressions in a week on my own.
You can buy those.
What does that have to do
with anything?
And I can sell ‐‐
I've already sold products.
Can I monetize
your impressions?
Do I get money for that?
You sold $42,000 worth.
No, because we haven't
done the push yet.
That was just to see
if the practicality was good.
Exactly ‐‐
I haven't even jumped on.
I had a product last year
on e‐commerce
that made $33,000.
I brought it on.
$9 million this year.
Cuban: Single‐serve,
take it with you,
portable,
preserve the environment.
That's all good.
But like any product, it comes
down to the actual design.
Like, I started playing with it,
and there's just
too many moving pieces
that you had to explain.
You're asking for $1 million,
and you haven't really
shown us anything
to say you deserve
$1 million.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Appreciate that.
I think it's a great product,
horrible design.
But let's put all that aside
for a sec,
because I love the concept,
I love you.
$1 million for 10%.
The challenge when you ask
for that kind of money
and a $10 million valuation
is you've gone out of the world
of belief and theory
and now you're
in the world of proof.
You have to give me proof
that it's worth that.
It's ridiculous.
I'm out.
You know what? It's still
an early‐stage prototype.
There's still a long journey,
so your valuation and the amount
of money you're asking
is just very hard.
And I'm actually, like,
sad and upset
because you have
great energy.
Yeah.
I love you guys.
Herjavec: It's so sad.
I'd love to be, but you made it
impossible for us.
So I wish you the best.
I'm out.
Greiner: It's clever.
I think that
always problem‐solution things
are great,
but today you came in asking
for $1 million for 10%,
and everybody said
sort of the same thing.
You guys, $1 million
is so much money.
‐It's just too rich.
‐You can still do that.
Is there a way
to shift your deal?
So, sadly, I'm out.
Thank you.
You know, I'm offended
at this valuation.
$10 million? That's obscene.
That's ridiculous.
It's stupid.
And as a result, you're going
to walk away with nothing.
‐That's ‐‐
‐And so it's your mistake,
not mine.
Our goal is
to have inventory.
I'm here.
I've got a million bucks.
But you're not getting
any of it,
zero, or any from anybody else
because of your mistake,
your greed,
your decision, your strategy,
even with the Rosco Man there.
It doesn't matter.
Mr. Wonderful, I don't plan
to pay myself
for the next few years
until this takes off.
The goal of this
is not to build wealth.
Who cares if you're paying
yourself?
It's a million bucks.
Anyways, guys, I'm out.
♪♪
Good luck, guys.
Congrats, man.
‐I hope it all works.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Thanks, Sharks.
Appreciate
the opportunity, too.
Thank you, guys.
‐Good luck.
‐See you guys.
‐Thank you, guys. Appreciate it.
‐[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
The Sharks will definitely
regret that,
'cause I do believe
that not investing in us,
they have lost
a big deal.
They might not
know it now,
but they will know it
in the years to come.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are entrepreneurs
who believe they have
something unique to offer
in a very crowded market.
♪♪
How's it going, Sharks?
My name is Maddie.
And I'm Paul.
We're seeking $150,000
for 5%
of our "fizz‐ness."
We all know
the sparkling water category
is bubbling over
right now,
but nearly every brand
has the same boring flavors,
uninspired packaging,
and often artificial
ingredients.
Aura Bora is a line of
herbal sparkling waters
made with sophisticated
ingredients,
eye‐catching branding,
and natural flavors.
Every can is filled with
real herbal extracts,
fruits, and flowers.
We like to say
it's just good clean...
...yum!
Yum!
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Come meet our five
heavenly varieties ‐‐
lemongrass coconut,
peppermint watermelon,
lavender cucumber,
basil berry,
and cactus rose.
We can't wait for you
to dive into those samples
in front of you.
So, Sharks...
"Water" are you waiting for?
[water]
Tada!
Whoo‐hoo!
[ Can tab pops ]
‐Oh, wow, that's very nice.
‐Wow, it's really nice.
Good.
Glad to hear it.
I was expecting yet another
bubbly water.
I'm not into the taste
of cactus.
Cactus is not my thing.
‐Oh.
‐Hey, herbal flavors
can be polarizing.
There's the one you hate,
one you love.
Yes, they can.
And that's okay.
‐Basil berry. I like it.
‐Great.
The lavender
is incredible.
‐The packaging is really fun.
‐Thank you.
That's the best seller?
Best seller right now.
Yes, sir.
Oh! Oh, oh, oh, lavender.
No, no, no.
Is there a calories in it,
Maddie?
Zero.
Zero calories, zero sugar,
zero sodium.
O'Leary: Is there artificial
sweetener of any kind?
Not at all.
‐That's fantastic.
‐Thank you.
‐What's your background?
‐Okay, so we're married.
I've spent my entire
short career ‐‐
I'm only 26 ‐‐
in branding.
I now work full time for
a tech company in San Francisco
on a branding team,
and I actually take
my marketing tips and tricks
I learn there home
and work as the creative
director for Aura Bora.
I'm on it full time,
so I work on Aura Bora
day in, day out,
weekends, late nights.
Previous to this,
I worked in finance.
So, Paul, I will say one thing.
We get so many beverage deals
in "Shark Tank."
Yeah.
I always admire the sheer guts
to come in here
with another beverage.
Before I just go into
my whole cockroach routine,
tell me, give me
one aura of hope,
even the slightest sliver
of a chance
that you can somehow
get distribution.
Yeah, great question.
We're already working with
the two largest natural food
distributors in the country.
We could scale our manufacturing
10 times at our current volume.
And then, finally,
we're getting great velocity
off shelves in stores
that we're sold.
What are your sales?
You have evidence of
sell‐through on shelf?
‐We do 100% sell‐through.
‐Where? Where?
We're in 488 stores
as of today.
‐Wow!
‐You actually have sales?
So, to date, we've done
$200,000 in sales.
‐Am I ‐‐ $200,000?!
‐$200,000.
We started selling this product
in January.
Cuban: What's getting
people to pick up?
Are you doing tastings?
Are you spending
a lot on promotion?
So, before COVID,
I was sampling four days a week,
as much as possible,
getting to know the consumers,
seeing their reactions,
et cetera.
During COVID,
we couldn't do that.
So it turned into a bit
of a telemarketing business
for a few weeks where I'd call
and ask as many employees,
"Hey, is it selling?
How's it going?"
So you're a true noodge,
right?
Oh, my gosh.
The number of stores
he's dressed up as not himself
to walk into and pretend
he's interested and ask
where the product is...
We need to get
honest feedback, right?
If you're at
a trade show...
Do you own 100% of the company?
Have you brought in investors?
Where are you at?
Yeah, we've raised
$700,000 to date.
‐Wow.
‐So right now,
we own 74% of the business
between the two of us.
Okay. So what does a can cost
at retail?
We make that can
for 57 cents.
We sell to our distributor
for $1.15.
It's exactly
a 50% margin.
And then it sells on the shelf
for $1.99.
We're going to end this year
somewhere between
$500,000 and $600,000.
Next year, though,
we are already in talks
with a number
of big‐box retailers.
We anticipate finishing
next year
between $2.5 million
and $3.5 million.
Listen, you two couldn't be
more appealing if you tried.
I think that you did
great marketing.
I like the name.
It's cute packaging.
It attracts the eye.
But I need to be passionate
about every investment I do.
I'm not passionate about
all the flavors, so I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Okay, listen.
Paul and Maddie, listen.
You've done
a very beautiful brand.
I do think you have a future.
But in order to succeed
in sparkling,
it's a very niche
proposition.
And for that reason, I'm out.
What's so great about
this product is we can get
70% gross margins
at scale.
We can be profitable in 2021
because it's mostly water.
I actually think you could
increase your price potentially.
Lubetzky: I don't think so.
That kills
your differentiation.
Paul:
That's right, yes.
That's your catch‐22.
Right, guys?
‐Right.
‐Yes, sir.
When you're small
and regional,
the velocity
that you're doing, it works.
But when you try to go
national like that,
that lid on margins
is really going to hurt you.
And so where somebody else
might have to sell X cans,
you have to sell
X times two or three.
‐Yeah.
‐And just dealing with
that volume
is an incredible challenge.
It's really a hurdle
for you guys.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Let me take a stab at it.
You know, you were in
a long line of beverage guys
that have stood there,
a moment of silence for them.
[ Laughter ]
But it's so crazy.
The chances of success are
abysmally low, unfortunately.
However, I've always wanted to
add a beverage to my portfolio
just because
I want to be miserable.
‐And...
‐After all that?
Here's how I'd do it.
I give you $150,000.
I want 5 cents a can until...
‐[ Chuckles ] Just what is this?
‐Wait, wait, wait for it.
[ Laughs ]
Wait for it.
Until I get back $300,000,
then the royalty goes away.
So I double my money
for taking the ride,
and I get 5%.
I want the misery.
I want the misery of what
happened last week.
He wants the nickel.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐So...
Kevin, thank you
for your offer.
That may be your worst offer
in 12 years.
[ Laughter ]
It really might.
Kevin loves the misery.
You know, I'm in
a different place in life.
‐I like happy.
‐You look happy.
I think you go national,
you may get big numbers quicker,
but it's going to crush you.
So for me,
the road is a little longer.
I think you have
such a unique product,
you can create
the pull through...
Yeah.
...maybe a little bit
along the road.
Are you giving an offer?
‐So my offer...
‐You want 6 cents a can.
[ Cuban laughs ]
I'll give you $150,000
for 12%.
‐Okay.
‐Wow! Do that.
‐So...
‐What do you want to do?
Yeah, so the royalty
is an interesting deal.
Kevin, we thought
you might say that.
[ Laughter ]
However, it feels like not
the most efficient way
to use our margin.
But you understand the problem.
I don't have a royalty deal.
That's why I'm coming
back to you, Robert.
Love your offer.
What would you think about
$200,000 for 10%?
I would do $200,000 for 15%.
[ Breathes deeply ]
Okay, um...
[ Cuban laughs ]
O'Leary:
It reflects the risk.
Would you do
$200,000 for 12%?
If so, we got a deal.
I'll do $200,000 for 15%.
‐Now you got me excited.
‐Robert!
‐15%! 15%!
‐Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
‐He said 15%!
[ Laughter ]
‐15%?
‐Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You might not be able
to go home, Paul.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
‐You got a deal!
‐Whoo!
‐Yay!
Paul: Come grab this.
Come grab this.
‐Okay.
‐All right.
‐We want to celebrate.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Okay.
‐Ready? Set?
‐1, 2, 3!
‐Go!
[ Poppers bang ]
[ All cheering ]
‐All right!
‐I'm so excited!
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐High fives! High fives!
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Those are great.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thanks.
‐Best of luck.
‐Well done.
‐Thank you.
So great to see
all of you.
‐Great job.
‐Nice to meet you all.
‐Thanks for your time.
‐Congrats.
‐Have a good one.
‐Whoo!
Paul: Robert has a lot of
experience in digital marketing.
He can help us build
a direct‐to‐consumer
digital beverage brand.
Hey.
On top of that,
he loved Aura Bora,
which means he can
definitely help sell it
and we'll keep his fridge
really well stocked.
Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a tool that solves
a messy problem
when caring for babies.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Alina Kravchenko.
I am from Houston, Texas,
and I'm seeking $120,000
for 10% of my company.
While some people
know me as Alina,
many of you parents
will soon know me as...
[ Twinkle ]
...your fairy godmother!
Let's get real.
Changing a diaper
can be a struggle.
First, you try getting
your wiggly baby
onto the changing table.
Then while safely
holding your baby with one hand,
you somehow try to apply
the ointment with the other.
Look at my poor mom.
She's getting it all over
her clothes, under her nails.
And she has to do this
up to 10 times a day!
It's exhausting.
Oh, no need to fear.
Your fairy godmother is here!
And I have a magical product
that will make
this problem disappear.
Ready, Sharks?
Bippity, boppity, boo!
[ Laughter ]
Introducing SwipenSnap,
the world's first and only
patented
one‐hand cream applicator.
After attaching it onto
your favorite diaper cream,
simply pull the tube
from the suction cup‐based lid,
squeeze a desired
amount of ointment,
and swipe it on your baby,
all with just one hand.
When I first had my son,
I was a young single mom
looking for ways
to make my life easier.
It's like what they say,
necessity is the fairy godmother
of invention.
So what do you say, Sharks?
Are you ready to swipe and snap
and live happily
ever after with me?
[ Laughter ]
‐Good job.
‐Tada!
‐Great job. Great job.
‐[ Clapping ]
You know,
I have 2 1/2‐year‐old twins.
I'm doing this
20 times a day.
‐Yes.
‐But I take this...
Yeah, right, Robert.
‐Oh, no, I am.
‐Yeah, right.
Oh, no, no, no, Mark.
I am, absolutely.
But I take this
to my existing cream?
Correct. So you take
the suction cup‐based lid,
place it onto
any hard surface.
‐Okay.
‐This is the applicator.
You take this, and you attach it
onto any diaper cream.
So then you pull, you squeeze,
you swipe, and snap.
And this gentle applicator's
super soft...
Cuban: Ooh, that's cool.
...and allows you
to control the amount.
‐Ohh.
‐It's very nice.
‐Just like that.
‐Alina,
this is an interesting
innovation.
But what I have
never seen before,
which is very important
to understand
that you have two
different‐sized bottles...
Yes. Exactly.
...and they both fit.
Is that something
you patented?
‐Yes, I did it myself.
‐You wrote it yourself?
I did.
And I did all the drawings.
Herjavec: How did you
learn how to write
a patent application?
I read "Patent It Yourself"
and put my baby down to bed,
and while he was sleeping,
read through it.
So, I invented this product
10 years ago.
Oh, wow.
‐10 years ago.
‐Yes.
You must have millions
in sales, right?
Well, I'm a single mom,
and [chuckles] it's been
a difficult road
being alone and with very
little connections and money.
That's why I'm here.
So you haven't sold any
in 10 years?
I have. I have sold.
My sales are relatively low
because I haven't ‐‐
Is there a number?
I haven't marketed
the product.
What's the number?
$15,000 year to sales.
In 10 years?
No, no, no. I ‐‐
I've been waiting
on the patent.
So about ‐‐ it took six and
a half years to get the patent.
I mean
five and a half years.
So the $15,000
is over what period of time?
Yes. I recently ‐‐ well,
two and a half years ago ‐‐
quit my job and decided to
bring this product to life.
But you've sold $15,000
in two years.
You can't live off that.
No.
‐So what have you been doing?
‐Are you working full time?
I...
I have an investor.
And he hired me part time
to help me run
one of his operations.
How much did he put in?
He put in,
as an angel investor,
5% for $60,000.
How much is it?
First run,
I was selling it for $10.
And because marketing
was very expensive ‐‐
‐$10?
‐Yes.
I increased the price
to $20, and people ‐‐
What did it cost you
to make it?
$1.85.
How did you sell
that $15,000?
Majority of it
came from organic sales
because when I did
a pre‐launch ‐‐
‐Online?
‐Online, yes.
Have you tried to go
into any retailers?
I was approached
by a lot of retails,
but I decided
not to go into retail
because I wanted to make
the product even better.
So I conducted
a market study.
Everyone that had bought
the first version,
I called them
and I asked them,
how can I make
this product even better?
Because my goal was to make
the best product I could.
So you said, "No,
I don't want to go to retail"?
‐I said not yet.
‐How long ago was that?
Three years. Two and a half,
to be exact, yeah.
Tell us about
your background.
My mom brought me
and my sister here.
None of us knew English.
‐From where?
‐From Ukraine.
And she taught me that America
is where dreams come true,
so dream big.
Herjavec:
What's your mom's name?
‐Svetlana.
‐Can you tell us, Svetlana ‐‐
Can tell us a little bit about
the journey of coming here?
I was grow up, and my kids
grew up in communism time.
I knew about America.
I was thinking about this dream
for my kids,
for my kids' opportunity.
It's a road, very long road to
come this country.
No family, no friends,
no speak English.
I'm so proud about my kids,
proud about Alina.
I ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
It's a dream come true.
You know, I come
from a communist country.
‐You understand.
‐I understand.
You know, my dad
was the youngest of 15.
‐Wow.
‐[ Gasps ]
And people used
to spit on him
because he wouldn't join
the Communist Party.
‐Oh, wow.
‐He got thrown in jail 22 times.
And the last time
he got thrown in jail,
they said, "If you come back,
you will never come back."
[ Gasps ]
Oh, my God.
And so we crossed
the border,
we come here,
and we have nothing.
Like, we had nothing.
But my dad was happy.
He would rather have nothing
but an opportunity.
‐Yeah.
‐Obviously, I think
it's one of the greatest
countries in the world.
‐We are same page.
‐Yeah.
Okay, Alina, let me
take a stab at it, okay?
It's got patents,
which you wrote,
which is ‐‐ was the first hint
that you're not nuts,
because that's hard to do.
But I wish
you had a partner,
another fairy sit beside you
that was pure executional skills
on digital marketing.
Mr. Wonderful,
I am that second person.
‐My background ‐‐
‐Well, you might be,
but you haven't convinced me,
and I'm the investor.
Let me. Let me.
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
Herjavec: It's obvious that
your drive is unbelievable.
‐Thank you.
‐I mean, I can't tell you
how many people
came up here
and spent $50,000,
$100,000 to get a patent.
You read a book
and got it on your own.
But my issue with it is,
as a new dad,
I don't know if I would
use this for the baby.
I could get around
all the other stuff,
but I got to believe
in the product.
For me, on this,
I'm out.
Does the patent cover
the ability
to fit with that double thing,
or does that already exist?
Yes.
No, it does not exist.
This is the only patent that has
that double‐threaded technology.
That's what
interests me.
I don't know, Lori,
if you're interested,
but if you're interested,
I would try to
commercialize that
while you figure out ‐‐
I'll tell you
what I'm thinking.
And if you want to, you know,
go in on this together...
[ Gasps ]
I think
what you did was smart.
Oh, thank you.
I like
the quality of this.
I was thinking
this is a licensing play.
‐Yes!
‐So, Daniel, you and I,
$120,000 contingent on that
the patent...
‐Okay.
‐...will allow us to license
this technology
for other things.
‐For 33.3%.
‐Yes!
‐We'll be 1/3 partners.
‐Yes! Really?!
She's going to fly away.
Oh, my God,
I mean, that's ‐‐
Yes. Well, do you
want to think about it?
No, no, I do. I do.
Let's negotiate.
I'm going to try to make sure
that you understand
what the offer is
from my side.
Yes. Got it.
What I'm most interested is
in commercializing
the double thread
in a variety of ways.
Got it. Got it.
Contingent on us
being able to do that,
then I would be in for
the journey of 33% of this
and 100% of any other uses
for the double thread.
‐You want 100%?
‐Of the double thread.
Okay.
You don't want to do that.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Daniel may be interested
in partnering with Lori
for Alina's diaper cream
applicator SwipenSnap,
but he wants 100% of the patent
for other uses.
What I'm most interested is
in commercializing
the double thread
in a variety of ways.
Got it. Got it.
Contingent on us
being able to do that,
then I would be in for
the journey of 33% of this
and 100% of any other uses
for the double thread.
‐You want 100%?
‐Of the double thread.
Okay, Alina, I want to throw
a wrench into this.
I think the innovation
is around the double screw.
I get that.
All this contingency
on this contingency on that.
I'll make a deal with Lori ‐‐
Wait a second. Hang on.
[ Laughs ]
I'll go 50%.
I want 25%.
I want her to have 25%.
I want us to be
50/50 partners with you.
I'm particularly interested
in licensing this
and working on that deal.
And you're kicking
Daniel to the curb?
Yes.
I'm throwing him under the bus.
Greiner: Listen, I agree
with the licensing
because I think that
this could be used
in a lot of
different ways.
Lori, are you in
on this deal with me?
Daniel, I would have loved
to have gone in with you,
but, Kevin,
I'm in with you.
All right. Alina, you got
two Sharks, Lori and I.
What do you want to do?
Could you take
a slightly smaller bite?
Listen, if we get you
a licensing deal,
you're just gonna sit back
and watch the money roll in,
the royalties roll in.
You don't have to do any work.
We're good at what we do.
Are you ready to go?
Kevin, would you consider
just a slightly smaller,
smaller bite?
Why do you care?
Yeah, you shouldn't care.
You're not selling anything now.
You have the power
of two Sharks
that have done licensing deals
their whole lives.
We're going to, like,
get this done for you.
You've had no sales.
It's been many years.
Like, this is
bird in hand.
And the thing is,
what you created
and what took a long time
to get out...
It's so good.
...is that you brilliantly got
these patents of value.
‐That's what happened.
‐Right.
But now we're going to
get to work and see if we can...
Okay.
...monetize it.
This is what I wanted.
Yes or no? Say yes.
I wanted both of you,
so I think ‐‐
You want to do it?
Yes!
Okay! Yes! Yes! Yes!
‐Yay! Get up, Kevin.
‐Ohh, my goodness.
I love you so much.
Oh, my gosh.
‐Congratulations.
‐Oh, my gosh, Lori and Kevin.
‐Spasíbo!
‐I am so excited.
‐Let's go make some money.
‐Yes.
‐Exactly.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughs ]
It's exactly what I wanted!
‐Oh, my God! I'm so excited.
‐Wow! Wow! Wow!
Even though I gave up
50% of my company,
I know that Kevin and Lori
are going to connect it
to the right people
and get it out there,
and that's what
I was looking for.
So I feel great about it.
♪♪